[موسيقى]
هناك هوس في سياتل
بالخطوط وسيقودونك إلى
القهوة ،
وبصفتي أحد محبي القهوة ، فإن هذا هو
الهوس الذي سأستمتع به بحرية إذا
أتيت إلى هنا كثيرًا ، نعم احتضنني هنا ، حسنًا ،
ستاربكس الممتازة لنحل القهوة العالمية
بدأت هنا ، ورغم أن حاضرها موجود في كل
مكان ، إلا أنها لم تمنع العشرات من
منافسيها الصغيرة من
فتح الكابتشينو وازدهاره ، من فضلك ،
هذه سرية حقيقية أحبها
[الموسيقى] ،
حسنًا ، إذا كنا سنصنع  12 أونصة
لاتيه هنا نذهب ، ستتذكر
تخمير الإسبريسو وفن اللاتيه كانا
مشروعي الوبائي الذي أجيده في البداية والخطوة
الأولى في
التحضير هي أنك تريد تحضير
الحليب الذي يمتلكه داني كوهن هذا المتجر العام
و  على وشك أن أصبح معلمي على
الفور في البداية ، هل يمكن أن
تجعلني أخيرًا أرسم بشكل صحيح على
الكريما ، أشر إلى أخطائي وأنا أمر بها ، حسنًا ،
جاهز لواحد
يأتي أولاً ، نريد تحضير
الحليب  أوه ، نعم ، هذا لم يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً ،
نعم ، حسنًا ، أنت جاهز ، أعني أنه
يمكنك فعل ذلك فقط ، فأنا أفهم
تمامًا افتتان داني
بالقهوة
هناك ، فنحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا ، لقد حصلت على
هذا ، لا استمر في السكب ،
استمر في السكب  استمر في التدفق لأنك
لم تبدو رائعًا ، هكذا
وقعت في حب صناعة القهوة
عندما كان عمري 15 عامًا وحصلت على أول وظيفة لي في باريستا
لأنه كان ذلك المكان الذي
وجدت فيه أيضًا مكانًا أذهب إليه حيث
يسعد شخص ما برؤيتهم
إذن صحيح للخروج
والركض
هنا ، لدينا حب للقهوة
وتحول الإحساس بالمكان إلى مهنة ، لذا
سأبدأها من هذه الزاوية
عندما افتتحت داني مقاهيها
والآن أصبح لديها متجر عام
يحتوي على قهوة.  شريط بالطبع إنه في
الدم إنه في الدم ، نعم لا أستطيع أن
أفعل ذلك ، لقد أحببت دائمًا
المتاجر العامة حتى قبل أن أعرف أنها كانت في عائلتنا
تتحدث عن
جدها الأكبر الذي شق طريقه إلى
سياتل في  في أوائل القرن العشرين ، افتتحت أيضًا
مخروطًا لمتجرًا عامًا وشتاينر ، وقد
عاودت الزيارة من خلال تسمية
متجرها العام الجديد CNS
Danny الذي لم ينته معي ، ولكن هناك
درسًا آخر تريد نقله ، لذلك
نريد أن نأخذك إلى
الموقع الأصلي  من كونان
شتاينر ، الذي كان يعمل فيه جدي الأكبر ، في أوائل القرن العشرين ، وهذا
عنوان يعرفه الكثير من الناس لأنك
ربما سمعت عن هذه
الشركة المحلية ، وهذا هو المقر الرئيسي الذي
تخبرني به أن
المتجر الأصلي لجدك الأكبر والذي من خلاله
المقهى هو النسب ،
نعم
هنا ،
لست متأكدًا مما إذا كانت هذه مفارقة أو
عدالة شعرية أعلم أنني أعلم أنه
نجاح غير متوقع لا يصدق
مرة أخرى في المقهى الذي يصل إلي
أيضًا أخيرًا ، فلنقم بذلك ، نعم هناك
إنه موجود  لقد عادوا
بهذه الطريقة ، سوف يأتون إلى هنا ،
استمروا في إلقاء
نظرة على هذا ،
نعم ،
هذا رائع
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك